isn't that so crazy like literally any
other vowel
would just not have worked we are about
to talk
about how to access everything that's
inside of you to create a song
i just want you music is more powerful
than any other
medium period where
if i wasn't an artist i would be a
teacher the coolest
teacher of all time
we're gonna go through songwriting
lyrics we're gonna talk about the
process so we are in
my vocal booth my vocal warmups sound
pretty crazy
also going to bring you into the studio
talk production
how to put everything together to really
create that beautiful piece that you
want to create if writing the song is
like the sketch
arranging the song and particularly the
vocals is like painting it
we're going straight to the heart boom
direct to me music is not technical
it's emotional and it always has to be
emotional we're talking about
freedom of expression and sometimes you
have to get loud
[Music]
every day you're different every day
you're growing
every day you're better i want to share
with you
how to find your own voice how to trust
it too
you know you have something to say the
world wants to hear it the world
needs it
[Music]
so if you're ready i'm ready are we
ready
yes
i'm alicia keys and this
is my master class
[Music]
can we please put the thing in there
[Music]
you